anybody get sal's [ __ ] christmas card
yet
yeah i did did you catch it he wrote the
governales and and he put an apostrophe
he sent out a christmas card to all his
family and friends with dumbass grammar
an apostrophe is possessive yeah you're
showing that you own something this is
the governale's house i looked at your
card i had a laugh sal you're the best i
mean everything you do is moronic did
you ask someone to look over your card
no i mean i put it together i thought
the apostrophe is like
i don't know like i thought the
government like if it's more than two
people it's
uh the and then an s like i don't know i
can't i thought it was an apostrophe i'm
sorry you put an s at the end of it but
you don't have
right that's what i thought yeah if it's
governelli it would be singular but if
it's covering alleys you add an
apostrophe s that's what i thought
because if you're heading the ass
because i i thought howard if you write
governales then you would think that
that's the exact last let me here's the
key let me let me interrupt you
with you when you go i thought how many
times have your thoughts been wrong i
mean you got to play the odds you go oh
if i'm thinking there's an apostrophe it
probably isn't one
why not if you don't know right just the
governor alley family and then you don't
have to deal with the yes or you have to
enter point check yeah well i've checked
on well i'm not that good with the
internet as well i've had some bad yeah
he wouldn't even know how to look it up
i don't i put garlic in my penis
you went to college right yeah yeah i
did suffolk community college yeah
lauren's suffolk community
i got the same [ __ ] yesterday about my
card well what'd you get your card your
card looked like an advertisement for a
casino right yeah it was ridiculous we
couldn't see you you could see the big
las vegas
i thought it was two nights at the
venetian
[Laughter]
yeah okay
so you got to send out a correction card
like hey
howard apology
how many cards how many christmas cards
did you send out i think 150
150 like hey i'm a [ __ ] card
ronnie uh love you a sal i love you and
you know what i got to say i did like
ronnie's card because uh you know i felt
happy ronnie's happy being in vegas he's
proud of it and now your family did look
beautiful i have to admit i howard i
love you guys love you robin so much and
everyone on the show i mean you guys
mean the world to me and i wish you
nothing but great health and a wonderful
loving holiday for you and your family
oh shut up you idiot
go [ __ ] yourself ronnie i love you ron
look at that what are you having a
nervous breakdown over there what are
you starting to cry what now i just like
you guys
[Laughter]